kim kardashian and north are no doubt
the most stylish mother-daughter duo in
paris after giving this twinning moment
at a couture show i love that that's the
two attending the jean-paul gartier show
at paris fashion week seated front row
of course and right next to vogue
editor-in-chief anna wintour
both kim and north are rocking pin
striped looks the nine-year-old wearing
a vest and her mama a dress both pairing
their looks with sunglasses to match
it's always so much fun
but that's not all because kim and north
also sported identical nose rings
so northie's clearly been taking fashion
cues from both her parents
it's so crazy on tuesday while out and
about with her mom in paris the little
fashionista was spotted wearing a piece
from her dad kanye west's archives
there she is donning a royal blue
letterman jacket from the rapper's
former pastel brand and the same jacket
he wore at the american music awards
back in 2008 she definitely has kanye's
outgoing personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend
and then she's also really calm and
sweet like me sometimes
and during this mother-daughter trip to
the city of lights kim also hit the
catwalk
[Music]
that's the beauty mogul walking the
runway for balenciaga show modeling a
black curve-hugging gown complete with
her newly blonde hair pulled back into a
bun
north was there in full support of her
mom and enjoyed the show right next to
her grandma kris jenner
[Applause]
now we're still keeping our fingers
crossed for a runway appearance from
north during paris fashion week because
we know she is no stranger to it you'll
recall her surprise performance at yay's
yeezy season 8 show back in 2020
[Music]
now whether north or her siblings saint
chicago and psalm follow following their
parents fashion or music footsteps kim
once told et they have her full support
in whatever direction they want to go i
hope that they
just find their own motivation and no
matter what that is no matter what they
want to do in life i hope that they work
really hard i think they have good
example i learned from seeing both of my
parents work really hard and i think our
kids will see you know
kanye and i work really hard and i hope
that's motivating for them and just to
find their own path
[Music]